one of the most interesting states
throughout European history has always
been the Holy Roman Empire made up of
who knows how many smaller
principalities kingdoms and bishoprics
the question is how did the Holy Roman
Empire work how did such a massive
collection of states with differing
interests managed to stay United for
nearly a thousand years given that the
Holy Roman Empire existed for so long
its administration obviously changed a
great deal
thus will pick the late 18th century to
look at because some of the old ways of
doing things were still around and the
politics was generally much more
interesting to so wise of the late 18th
century the Holy Roman Empire was
divided like this the arch Duchy of
Austria was the most important of these
lands and was home to the Hapsburg
imperial family roughly 1/3 of the
Empire's lands was controlled by the
Hapsburgs with another 20% being part of
Prussia and the rest being ruled by the
others as of 1765 the head of the
Habsburgs was joseph ii who held several
imperial titles the most important of
these was obviously that of holy roman
emperor which was an elected position
elections weren't open to the public or
anything that would be silly in during
elections there were only nine eligible
voters these voters were the sovereign
rulers of these lands and included
people like Maria to raise a Joseph's
mother King George the 3rd of the United
Kingdom who was also the king of Hanover
and frederick ii of prussia better known
as frederick the great so how exactly
did this emperor run his empire well in
a word barely whilst the numerous rulers
whose rooms made up the empire did
promise to remain loyal to the emperor
in reality those promises were worth
sweet nothing many states within the
empire known formally his estates fought
wars against each other sided with
foreign powers against the emperor and
generally just did as they pleased
there was no fixed capital in the
administration of the empire was mostly
done from wherever the Emperor was at
the time which at this point was mostly
Vienna the Empire was formally
subdivided into what are called Imperial
circles for the purposes of
administration and for the collection of
taxes so the Emperor was the embodiment
of the executive arm of government but
his authority over the rest of the
Empire could be pretty weak at times
obviously the sole meant that the HRE
had an extremely weak central authority
that largely relied on the big scary
austrian army in a fear of outside
invasion to keep it all together
that said there were arms of government
which could and did act with authority
across the empire the first was the
legislative arm personified in the
Imperial diet which was based in
Regensburg this was the primary means of
representation for the individual
estates and their rulers the diet was
made up of three
actions called colleges college number
one was the electoral college made up of
the electors of the Empire whose task it
was as previously said to be bribed by
the hapsburgs into electing them as
Emperor college number two was the
college of princes basically the rest of
the nobility whose job it was to stop
the electors and Emperor from stomping
on them College number three was the
College of Cities made up of
representatives of the Free Cities of
the Empire and this was by far the least
important section of the diet so the way
it legislated was that the Emperor's
representative most often the Archbishop
of maine's would bring a proposition to
the diet to be voted into law the
electors read one vote each would decide
whether or not they would support this
Lauren if a majority supported it it
would be brought to the princes the
princes also got one vote each with some
exceptions in which certain lands were
grouped together in what are called
benches benches had one collective vote
and because of dynastic politics some
Prince's got several also some of these
princes like the electors were heads of
foreign states and so for an interest
led to a lot of gridlock
anyway if a majority of the princes
agreed to a proposal then it would
become law and if not then things would
be negotiated and to leave there it did
or until everybody went home the college
of free cities also got a vote but it
was only advisory and thus everybody
ignored it alongside the diet there were
two high courts the imperial chamber
council based in FETs LA and the owlet
council based in vienna both courts a
jurisdiction across the entire empire
but only the outlet council could deal
with criminal cases and importantly
feudal ones
ie it dealt with cases of people
disobeying their superiors in rank
something of particular interest to the
Holy Roman Emperor all of this led to an
often divided Empire whose estate seldom
agreed on anything and would undermine
their rivals in the Emperor whenever it
suited them at the religious divide the
rise of Prussia is a counterbalance to
the hapsburgs and the ability for
foreign rulers to interfere in its
internal processes and its long-term
weakness isn't all too surprising I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to my
patrons that you see on screen now and a
special thanks to James Bissonnette as
ARCA flash mark H party-boy Co David
archaeologist Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swann
onion duck
David Silverman Paul Maggie packs Kowski
Winston K wood vasily era vedas
christian check' anthony Beckett
Skye Chappell Adam Harvey and Ike